hey guys Pete here it's been a while but
there has been some new Game of Thrones
news so this will be my weekly spoiler
report if you don't like set production
spoilers or news about what the cast is
doing and what's going to happen in
season seven then you're going to want
to stop watching now with that out of
the way let's jump right into it
earlier this week we got some photos
from Iceland and initially it was just
crew members who were there we actually
got quite a few photos of them which a
Reddit user named JD [ __ ] Stark compiled
together on the free folk subreddit most
of the crew you wouldn't know but these
guys are supposedly related to costumes
which means that it's not likely that
they're there just to shoot scenery for
the backgrounds and things like that
we also found out that they were going
to be there for a few weeks which meant
that we expected to see at least some
shooting with the cast four scenes that
were beyond the wall now this isn't to
be confused with the rumors that we had
earlier that there was a location that
was in my other videos where we had like
a sort of ditch or a dolly something
like that you know like a corridor in
the ice this is a totally different
location and if you remember back to
seasons two and three I mean when they
were beyond the wall those were great
locations and that is sort of what we're
looking at here in these photos from
Instagram
sure enough Kit Harington was spotted
there in the next day or so
so we knew that this was probably
related to the story that we've been
following at the Wolf Hill quarry scene
not really sure how it ties together
like will they be ranging around looking
for this bite that they're supposed to
be bringing back to King's Landing or is
it all going to be tied together in some
other way on top of Jon Snow we got
Thoros and Joe Dempsie who plays Gendry
that showed up which also ties into the
whole expedition to capture the white
but like I said it's not clear whether
part of this is background to lead up to
that scene they've been shooting on the
frozen lake that they set up in Northern
Ireland
we're just going to have to wait and see
knowing what we know about the directors
and where people have been up into this
point though it's definitely clear that
they're not going to be beyond the wall
for a very long period of time so one
way or the other these two will be tied
together and it will all lead up to what
we talked about is most likely going to
be the epic battle scene of the season
which will happen in you know because
this is the shorter season of seven
episodes that will happen in episode six
so it's not a lot of set news or
spoilers like when you're used to but we
got to take what we can get at this
point beyond Iceland I don't know that
they're going to be filming anywhere
else outdoors so things are going to get
a lot quieter but I'll be keeping my
eyes peeled for any news that comes
around and non show related news we did
get one interesting tidbit that was
reported on a whole lot but it didn't
really say that much on his personal
blog george RR martin said that he
thinks winds of winter will be out in
2017 it was a response to a comment
where someone told him that he ought to
give us all a break basically and give
us an update and his exact words are you
really think statements like that would
make a difference
ah you sweet summer child I have years
of experience with this that tells me
otherwise but okay I'll try it your way
not done yet but I've made progress but
not as much as I hoped a year ago when I
thought I'd be done by now I think it'll
be out this year but hey I thought the
same thing last year and it was sounding
really great up to that last little bit
because we know this takes time and with
most of us thinking that it was going to
be coming out this spring that's pretty
much off the table according to what he
said just now but I mean it is a glimmer
of hope we can hope to get it around the
same time season 7 comes out or you know
right after but I'm not holding my
breath that we're going to get it and
read it before we actually start
watching the next season in case you
haven't been following he did do an
interview where he talked about how it's
going to be really dark and that's not a
big surprise to all of us who've been
waiting for this book winter is the time
of death and dying and
that's what he's basically saying is
going to be going on not necessarily in
the character sense but just that it's
going to be a tough time for everyone
one more show related to that we got it
was really just a confirmation though it
had been reported that Tom hopper was
going to be playing dick and Tarly and
we found out for sure that's the case
Freddie stroma who played him in the
last season told IGN that he would be
not able to carry on with the show
because of other commitments this isn't
a big surprise to us but like I said it
is a confirmation so regrettably that's
going to be it for this installation not
any other real news to report on Game of
Thrones was nominated for various awards
nothing really to point out I guess I'm
still a little bit jaded over the whole
Golden Globes thing they didn't win any
and tangi Newton didn't win for West
world so the award type is a little bit
low on my priority of things right now
as far as my channel is concerned I've
been taking a break just because of the
poor time of the year for YouTube I've
got a bunch of different stuff I'm
planning to put it out over the next
couple weeks now that everything's back
in swing I didn't want to have a bunch
of videos come out that would not get
watched because after doing a little bit
of research I found out that the first
two weeks of January are the worst weeks
for views and for ad income so it just
seemed like a good time to head to
Thailand so that's where I've been at
and like I said I'll probably do some
more as a spoiler recaps but I wanted to
wait and see what we find out about
Iceland which I'm talking about today
because that's going to be like one of
the last you know big things that we
have as far as filming goes so please
like the video if you enjoyed it make
sure you leave a comment if you have any
questions or any theories about what's
going on north of the wall the book
giveaway is still going on and all you
have to do is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video or any of the
other ones that I mention this giveaway
in when I reach 20,000 subscribers I
will give away the 20th anniversary
edition of a game of Thrones by George R
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon